little Amelia may not know it but she
played a role in the fateful
circumstances that saved her family and
relatives from serious injury and
possibly much worse it was her baptism
that brought the family together in his
picturesque region of Chile for a
celebration a celebration on the night
the region would be struck with the
worst earthquake in Chile in 50 years
about 50 miles away in Santa Cruz the
February 27th earthquake knocked a
three-story apartment building down to
two stories where 23 people died damage
in the region can be seen everywhere you
turn the Lowell is in the heart of
Chile's winemaking region grape vines
cover much of the landscape the la la
acción de now operated as a restaurant
by the Mujica family was bought in 1891
by Donna Vita and since then his
descendent family has grown now more
than a hundred strong it was here on
February 27th where the relatives
gathered for Amelia's baptism
celebration gusta mucho
mihika family always likes to have a
good time because they celebrate
everything a lot grandly so the
christening of young Amelia for instance
was a marvelous chance to be here
because only within the family members
you could count 60 or 80 people and all
in a party mood it's late summer in
Chile and a Friday night everyone was
outside eating drinking and dancing into
the early morning hours and the 8.8
earthquake struck
when the shaking stopped parts of the
building behind them had fallen apart
miraculously no one was inside but next
door an uncle 64 year old Nana Mujica
was inside his home it collapsed on top
of him he did not survive such a warm
man very kind they don't know but it was
simple but very honest and real so yes
it is a real pain of the soul if the
remote assume with what this earthquake
has been very strong here I believe all
these houses all over this region were
built to resist a certain degree of
earthquake but this one beat it all in
every degree and destroy them all
practically all my cousin's my uncle's
my Godfather's they all have lost their
houses they are all living in tents now
so all the neighbors well I got some you
buddy
this is the house where my father raised
us seven brothers I am the fourth one
here you can appreciate the results of
the earthquake in the house we are a big
family each one has lots of sons and
that has bonded us giving us the
strength to keep going how can I put it
because I'm very touched how can I
explain everyone is helping out
cooperating with all their hearts dad
you have to rebuild the house they say
and the brothers agree now the family is
together again not for celebration but
to clean up what's left oh I feel it's
been very sad this thing we are well we
don't know what to do we are left with
no house this house is lost it is all
broken the roof tiles if you look at it
from the outside there's not one roof
tile in place this house is through is
over
I somehow blocks it that night it is the
fear the anguish so very special second
D I get for that yeah I just wanted
Amelia's baptism to be here at our house
with the little chapel because all my
family is going to be here and amelia is
the first great-granddaughter
my grandfather was so proud belladonna
trophy one man on who have lost our
cousin nah no we all got together
yesterday and we had a beautiful mass in
front of the very house it destroyed
daliyah
he dama thorn and all the cousins were
there he couldn't stop saying hi to
everyone it was very emotional maybe the
house will fall to the floor
but we will still be in love with the
place Tonto told aunt in Tennessee is it
okay kneel at the sedan in the Casa
traditionally to treasure these all big
four but everyone understands these
things fall apart this tight-knit
Chilean family has new memories both sad
and joyous and it has a story to pass to
the new generations about how one little
infant through fate saved mojitos from
an even worse outcome in their country's
devastating earthquake
you